then there is the televised mental
institution known as
msnbc and they have this
certified lunatic i mean a racist crazy
woman who does a show in the middle of
the day i think
joy reid and she just wants you to know
that uh you know republicans they love
death definitely not online where anger
and alienation and fear just feast on
places like 4chan and 8chan and they
know it and rupert murdoch's marionettes
are pulling those themes right onto
their primetime shows
republicans have literally made bringing
trump and his dangerous paranoid style
back onto twitter into a political
rallying cry and okay set aside
ideological or emotional safety we're
not allowed to feel physically safe
anywhere in america thanks to
republicans ironclad partnership with
the bloodsoak nra which long ago quit
the gun safety business and has been
working for decades to ensure that the
most lethal arms get into as many
alienated 18 and 19 year old in-cell
hands as possible so that we can't feel
safe at walmart at the supermarket
at bible study or church service
at the salon
at the hospital if god forbid some guy
gets mad at his doctor for not giving
him opioids at a nightclub at a concert
even at a funeral
or at school
whether you're in high school or you're
10
and in the fourth grade
in america and only in america you are
literally rolling the dice
every time you leave your house or drop
off your kids at school and you just
have to pray that today is not your day
or their day to meet that angry
alienated american man with an ar-15
this weekend alone we had a greater
number of mass shooting deaths in the
u.s
than last week's three-day weekend when
last week's three-day weekend when 17
were killed and more than 70 were
injured in mass shootings across the
country
today multiple democratic members of
congress attended a rally student
activists held at the capitol to call
for action meanwhile the other political
party refuses to do anything to solve
the problem of gun violence and don't
let anybody tell you that we couldn't
solve it that is just not true
but republicans want you to just get
used to feeling this way
unsafe
everywhere all the time
maybe in exchange for a few tax cuts
that honestly don't get to you anyway
because they're really for rich people
or so you can say ha i don't have to use
the pronouns victory
all so that they can have more power
which by the way they're going to use to
give more rich people more stuff and to
take more stuff from regular people like
you
while you hold your breath
every time you go to a store or drop off
your kids at school that's the bargain
are you okay with that
you see what they do
imagine the mental state you'd have to
be in if you watch that channel all day
long the endless psychotic
fear
that keeps you watching uh also it's not
literally roll the dice unless people
are literally playing craps all day long
lady it's metaphorically roll the dice i
use the word literally liberally
sometimes myself but that's just an
aside but if you're watching that and
you're listening to her and then you
walk outside you think you're going to
be shot you go to the hair salon and you
think you're going to be shot you go to
the hospital and you think you're going
to be shot strangely i'm guessing that
joy reid i'm willing to make a 10 bet on
this one there was a crazy stabbing at
the encino hospital which is where i
used to live in los angeles a couple
days ago a crazy person just busted into
the hospital and stabbed a couple nurses
and doctors
i'm guessing she didn't cover that now
it didn't have the weapon of choice and
it happened in cali and she wouldn't
want people to think bad things are
happening in cali because it's got all
sorts of
laws around people doing bad things
but these people their hypocrisy is off
the charts and also the idea that the
nra now you again we can all have an
honest assessment and disagreement about
some of the things related to guns okay
and whether it should be uh 18 to buy a
gun or 21 to buy a gun or why you'd be
able to say buy a gun at a certain age
but you still can't vote or dr or buy a
beer et cetera et cetera there's
legitimate stuff to talk about but they
want you to constantly be in fear and
they also want to constantly attack the
organizations that are defending our
right to defend ourselves right
governments should not uh people should
not fear their governments governments
should fear their people if you haven't
seen v for vendetta in a while i highly
recommend it um and that is what they
are trying to take away from us the nra
how many of the mass shooters were nra
members i'm going to guess it's zero i'd
love to be fact checked on this we can
try it real time if you want how many
mass shooters in the united states were
members of the nra i would bet you it is
zero the nra takes their job very
seriously you may not like some of the
things they do i don't need to make this
about the nra and i'm not going to sit
here defending every every policy
decision that they've done but the point
is there are all sorts of organizations
that help good people learn about what
their rights are good people learn about
uh weapons safety etc etc so uh this
attack this idea
that the republicans just want to work
with the honorary and they want
blood-soaked people and they want you to
be freaking out when you're going to the
ymca or when you're going to chipotle it
ain't true oh and thank you for chat
fact checking me live we love that from
quora.com uh zero mass shooters were
registered uh nra members so chalk one
up for me